welcome to spoiler corner okay so first
it's Deadpool's baby - yes for anyone
that like saw the review was just like
hasn't seen the movie just goes what and
you just watch it nope that was that's
explains my yes ngi and I'm just like
well he gets his legs chopped up and so
he grows new ones but it's like I don't
know like a four year olds like in these
like spreads is like Basic Instinct
sound there's a CGI and I my jaw just
dropped I was just like what like okay
like they did that all right like so
that's what a few I think that and then
him quote unquote dying at the end those
are like the only two jokes where I was
like it's going on a little bit you go
cut this down because they're just
talking about the baby later like so so
yeah let's say spoiler corner killing
her off in the beginning I like that at
all
like yes very a woman in the fragilis it
was it was totally girlfriend in the
fridge and the ending in my opinion if
they stick with it redeemed it cuz I'm
like if she's dead for good I'm I'm
gonna be pissed
yeah this ending like I was like my wife
and I considered this one of the
greatest dart like the first one of the
greatest dark romantic comedies ever and
thought they were adorable together
now I know why they didn't released this
on Valentine's Day yeah so I'm just like
if they seriously like stick with this
and like so that ending where he like
reverses time and everything like she
saved I'm like okay good I will return
to my wife we like high-fived each other
like fuck yeah but that does raise all
the questions like is that just an after
credit sequence or did all this stuff
happen or not happen it's cable against
either like how does this work
I don't know all I know is she better
damn well be alive but yes yeah very
much gives a fuck it's Deadpool yeah
well I mean but that I get it kind of
feels like a studio thing or it's like
well we'll see cuz we're not sure oh
very alive because I was that that was
pissing me off it's like so really
pissing me off
not in that like would you point Ram it
supposed to be yogi
they're even the characters like no it's
just annoying me because I was like no
that's lazy writing and that is even
done to wait I'm not the wink-wink lazy
writing kind of way I'm just like no
that's just fucking lazy writing there's
no way to ironically get out of that
with a joke yeah I'm like it was lazy
writing and I'm just like okay if you
did it this one since she's alive anyway
it was a plot point to get through this
I will I will give you a pass yes every
freaking lie you know and those credits
where they're like you know what they
killed her off what and I'm thinking to
myself that this is not that new a trick
this neck has been done a lot so I feel
like not that one of you who you and
that's what I was talking about when I
was just like you know what you can make
fun of the tropes but you're only gonna
get so far you just eat it out in this
movie like he just got a pass because
I'm like okay the ending redeemed in it
was funny but I'm like I they better not
do that again
like the romance was a good chunk of the
fun in the first one it was so which if
this was fine for what they did
but yeah you're right that was part of
the fun it's very the ewoks movies where
the whole first film is then saving the
family then the family just dies in the
furnace Endor which scarred us as
children yeah that's race you are
Stardust messed up the two x-men team
jokes one is that how you really do have
the whole cast they're bad at is the
door oh my god in the way like they all
look like shhh yeah it's always just
Lillian for you guys yeah just off to
the side the Clos like the whole team's
end they just closed the door and I'm
like that was brilliant like that's one
of the best jokes in the movie yeah the
x-force doesn't even make a whole day
together they all died except for Domino
she makes it yeah although I was a
little when the guy says the moe
Jew universe there was a party that's
just like Oh My Christ how amazing would
it be how much of just a middle finger
almost but to do an x-men movie based on
mojo and it's like the most authentic
x-men movie the only thing big the only
x-men will you really got everything
right and it's mojo like one of the most
unnecessary areas of what you know I
love to see imagine that's no I mean
that would be cool uh maybe well I mean
the dipper verse time so in theory
guitar the soundtrack has so many dreams
my yeah I just realize like there are so
many chick flicks off that's what I like
about the first one is it's the darkest
chick flick ever like like my like my
wife and I saw the Valentine's Day and
she's like that Valentine's Day movie I
ever saw and I might be doing it like
that's it see it brought people together
yeah broadcast so that's why this would
annoy me with that move they made them
begin but I'm like they may have
redeemed themselves so the the
juggernaut I thought was pretty cool
yeah and I'm gonna feel like I like the
juggernaut fine in the third one this is
the comic Joker and I like that was yes
I couldn't figure it out cuz I just kept
forgetting I was like what would there
be and I'm like yeah yeah juggernaut
like I keep forgetting they hi he did
everybody yeah Shh you know I mean like
a second see these x-men movies just
cannot find their path
but again buff the selfish part of me is
like I want to see juggernaut I want to
see Colossus I watching them as they are
so it's like cool but it is harder to
get into the universe oh and then the
end credits bit where he starts
reversing time and then goes back to
x-men origins Wolverine or whatever
shoots yeah and then shoots the old
Deadpool version of himself and
and when it shows him like as Ryan
Reynolds reading the script for the big
Lantern it's just like you finally made
it to the big time buddy welcome to the
bigs get shot in the head and then
temple behind him you're welcome Canada
that was like that got the biggest laugh
like I think of a theater that we just
had himself it's like this young naive
like hi here I'm gonna make it like it's
gonna be okay I mean it's just anyway
cuz we review that movie that movie's
legit terrible yeah um and the funny
thing is I never I never felt the need
to blame Ryan Reynolds I felt he was
miscast and that whatever they whoever
was the direction on him was all wrong
like just everything was wrong it didn't
work but so and he was just an interview
recently and he revealed again lays is
like yeah like Green Lantern was a low
point for me and this is it so it's like
that must have been cathartic for him
just to just be like yeah people I know
people work so hard on movies and stuff
like that um you have to turn it into
that hard but it's like that movie is so
old now and it's like I think it is but
all these people have gone onto other
crews cathartic for him and I feel like
it was cathartic for us and all of those
who watch Green Lantern like you know
just to see even him just be like no
after this movie was terrible it felt
really good I think it felt good for
everybody to see that but for me it's
more knowing that Ryan Rosen was such a
Deadpool fan and having him do that in
x-men origins yeah you know that badly
just knowing that's like this isn't
anywhere Clyde wanted to play I think
both of them work together because yeah
it's Deadpool killing the old Deadpool
in that sense and him being such a
Deadpool fan but in the case of Green
Lantern it's him living his dream of
bringing Deadpool to life killing the
oldest studio piece of crap that he had
the star and the old version of him that
thought you know this was gonna be the
ticket cuz I don't think it was I think
it set him back yeah Green Lantern sent
him back and like in a weird way that
also got him out of that
in the you-know-what though in a weird
way I feel like maybe this all work for
the best cuz Deadpool is his kind of
passion project here and I feel like
maybe if he had success with Green
Lantern doing what he would have gone
off with that would be like well no you
can't do to your Green Lantern now you
can't do this hour rated stew like
you're now in these PG pg-13 comic book
movies you know like so maybe it worked
out for the bus like maybe that being a
disaster actually is what led him here
so it's either way I thought it's just
one of the best scenes in the movie that
end credits sequence no yeah and then
nothing at the end like except for yeah
like don'twe Jesus like thanks I waited
like two minutes for that yeah they they
tell all that people just member piracy
is wrong we're not gonna give you your
end credits to you but piracy is wrong
and you know like all the Deadpool
trolls out there ago like be like I'm
gonna pirate the hell out of this just
for that for not giving me the anchor I
feel like you just increased the chance
that this film is gonna get pirated by
making a whole bunch of Deadpool fans
who are all trouble is to begin with
wait for nothing yeah and and on that
but ya can't no that was pretty much it
I just want to mention those legs
because I thought they were great so
yeah except for the first one which I
well the first one was the baby dick and
I thought that was awkward
girlfriend all I thought was not great
so but apart from that I thought
everything else was great yeah no I did
sell the movie man
yeah and that x-men that made me laugh
so hard yeah that's probably the hardest
I laughed oh you know what the one thing
I wish I didn't have you know I
understand Lisa but no Hugh Jackman I
thought they would have had him actually
oh yeah like I know like they use the
footage of him from x-men origins but I
really thought they would have had him
walk on or do something again maybe the
third film made they're saving it but
the save it save the best for less maybe
yeah but hear what they did with x-men
origins
so um yeah that's about it go see it
what if you're watching as you've
already seen it but ya know you're just
going for Punisher anyway yeah it's good
just had to know the baby dick yeah it's
alright Reynold so I guess that's how
they got around it
so yeah that's about it we'll see you
later
you